and the Cancer Genome Project is an
attempt to bring the human genome to the
understanding of how cancers develop
when our bodies are composed of cells
human body has about a hundred million
million cells within it
and usually those cells behave in a very
ordered fashion they observe certain
rules they divide when they're told to
divide the quiescent when they're told
remain quiet they stay in a particular
position within their tissue they don't
move out of that occasionally however a
single cell of those hundred million
million cells decides to behave in a
very different way that cell keeps on
dividing when all its signals around it
tell it to stop dividing that cell
ignores its colleagues around it and
pushes them out of the way that cell
stops observing the rules of the tissue
within it within which it is located
and begins to move out of its normal
position invading into the tissues
around it and sometimes entering the
bloodstream and becoming a metastasis
depositing in another tissue of the body
and the reason that the
behaves in this rogue fashion is because
it has acquired within its genome within
its DNA a number of abnormalities that
cause it to behave ever cancer cell
because all these hundred million
million cells in the human body have got
a copy of the human genome they've got
two copies the maternal and paternal
copy and throughout life all those
copies of the genome in those 100
million million cells are acquiring
abnormalities so-called somatic
mutations these are mutations that are
present in the cell they're not
transmitted from parents to offspring
they're just constrained to that
individual cell and it's progeny and
those mutations occur in every cell of
the body normal and abnormal for a
number of different reason they occur
because although we have an
extraordinary mechanism for replicating
DNA for those 3,000 million letters of
code we replicate each time a cell
divides hardly any mistakes are made
despite that extraordinary mechanism the
occasional mistake is made basically
every time a cell divides possibly one
letter of code is read out of the 3,000
million is replicated wrongly
so that's one source of mistakes one
source of somatic mutations however in
addition to that it's all these hundred
million million cells in the body are
being exposed to a number of different
on slots there's radiation of various
sorts which is hitting us the whole time
natural radiation we are a bag of
chemicals chemicals who regenerate
ourselves but chemicals that we also
ingest or exposed to and those also can
bind to DNA and can cause mistakes in
replication of DNA to be more common
and finally we have this mechanism these
processes that allow DNA to be
replicated in this highly faithful way
this high fidelity mode but occasionally
those mechanisms in a particular cell
may break down and then the DNA of that
cell begins to acquire mutations somatic
mutations rather more commonly than
other cells so you put all that together
every cell in the body is acquiring
mutations throughout a lifetime and as
we get older we acquire more and more of
them as it turns out most of those
mutations are completely innocuous they
make no difference at all
they make no difference to the cell
itself and certainly they make no
difference to us as multicellular
organisms that's basically silent they
sit there we live with them occasionally
however a mutation takes place in a
particular type of gene which in an
operative way we now call a cancer gene
and what that mutation does it changes
that particular gene and of course the
protein that it makes such that now that
abnormal protein is driving the cell to
behave in that unusual rogue fashion
that we call a cancer